[Music]
PIPP tries to be as plastic free as
possible they only come in that hard
crunchy plastic
she lives in Bedford but shops here at
Earth Natural Foods in North London
instead of shower gel I can buy loose
soap here her motto is zero waste and
she says there aren't many big
supermarkets helping with that I think
the reason that people don't do it is
just because it isn't readily available
they come so lucky to have found
somewhere like this but they're not
gonna be high-street they're not
available like supermarkets are she
agrees with a new campaign to introduce
a plastic free aisle in every major
supermarket to cut the amount of
packaging that finds its way to the sea
eight million tons of it ends up in the
ocean every year the contents of one
rubbish truck every minute one estimate
suggests that by 2050 the plastic in
oceans will weigh more than all the fish
a big part of the problems the
disposable stuff across Europe 40% of
all plastic is only used once and it's
mostly packaging we have a lot of choice
about what kinds of foods we buy whether
it's gluten-free fat-free sugar-free or
we have much less choice about is how we
buy it what it comes in it's virtually
impossible to buy all of your food
without some kind of plastic packaging
that's why activists from the
organization a plastic planets will be
lobbying big British supermarkets in the
next few weeks asking them to offer food
in biodegradable materials I think the
days of look at the supermarket's no
evil corporations you don't understand
what customers need those days are gone
I think supermarkets want to be part of
this change the issue in plastics is
very very urgent we need to do something
now we can't wait until 2020 so I think
working collaboratively with the
supermarket's
rather than premium campaigning against
them and then the mappings may change is
the way forward
it comes after skies ocean rescue
campaign was launched to raise awareness
of the damage being done to sea life
and mindsets need to change according to
John Grayson who owns this food store he
says not using packaging actually costs
less
we're buying typically twenty five kilo
sacks tip it out and customers help
themselves less that we don't have to
buy the packaging for that and it's
generally cheaper at source if we buy in
bulk campaigners say global ecosystems
are dependent on our oceans and yet
simple steps taken in supermarkets could
be part of the solution adele Robinson
Sky News North London well as you
probably seen Scala is leading efforts
to tackle the problem of plastic and how
it is affecting our oceans with our own
campaign Ocean Rescue you can join us
visit sky ocean rescue comm for more
details about how to get involved and
how to cut down the amount of plastic
you use follow us on Facebook or Twitter
at sky ocean rescue and join the
conversation using hashtag ocean rescue